vous avez été élu sur une liste
dissidente sans l'investiture reprise
officielle de votre parti des
républicains
est ce que vous aller siéger au sein du
groupe des républicains ici au sénat
alors j'ai été élu l air un lac
étiquettes et l'air donc nous allons de
nos thèmes temps écrit les dominati de
voir un petit peu comment les choses
évoluent seins c'est très important là
encore de prendre son temps dans les
jours dans les semaines qui viennent
trois sénateurs de droite ont été élus
sans l'investiture officielle du parti à
paris est ce que c'est un camouflet pour
la direction nationale des républicains
alors camoufler c'est un terme encore
une fois qui est pour moi un petit peu
péjoratif je n'ai pas un esprit
belliqueux mais je pense qu'il est très
important que nous tirions les
conséquences après chaque scrutin de ce
qui a pu se passer
alors il est évident que la liste
officielle ayant fait un petit peu moins
de 10% des voix à paris nous en ayant
fait 15 % il faudra quand même bien
souligner que c'est une forme de désaveu
pour la décision qui a été prise par le
parti d'investir cette liste officielle
qui n'est pas révélatrice de ce
souhaitait visiblement les grands
électeurs
et ça c'est important tirer les
conséquences vraiment parce que nos
électeurs nous le demande en permanence